كل الاماكن رحت فيهن انا ما وانا واولادي
انقصف كله اجري انا واياهم والصواريخ
نازله وين ما اروح في مش عارفه وين اروح
ولا اي ماوى يقويني وين في منطقه امنه في
غزه عشان اقعد فيها امنو لنا منطقه نقعد
فيها احنا واولادنا ما فيش امكانيه تواصل
لا معنا نشحن جوالاتنا ولا معنا اي شي
معناش يعني انا هي طلعت معايا بس جنيه
اعبيها ميه اشرب اودي ما معيش ولا اي شي
سيبنا بيوتنا وما
طلعنا يعني والقصف شغال من جنب الحيطان
نمشي ونشوف الناس بتقصف وبتطير قدامنا
واحنا بنمشي رسالتي للعالم انا بني ادم
عدي وصلت ل 40 سنه عشت كل حياتي حروب كل
حياتي حروب اكم مره شجعيه تتهدد يشيلوها
ونعاود نبني وتعاود تروح نبني لامتى يعني
لامتى لامتى وقتش احنا بنضل حالنا وضعنا
زي
هيك بدنا منطقه امنه تحطنا فيها لما فيها
حروب يكون فيها نلاقي ميه نلاقي ماقوى
نلاقي ششي نقعد ادنا نقعد في منطقه
امنه